-It is time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-We do this thing every week
where I send out a hashtag
and ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
So since the Olympics are here,
I sent out the hashtag
"Describe a sport badly,"
asking you to pick a sport
and describe it in a weird
or unusual way.
Within minutes,
it was a trending topic,
so thank you for playing along.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I appreciate that.
We do it every week.
Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite responses
with you guys.
This first one
is from @DontThinkso555.
They said...
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @reneejordan78.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This one's from @ZackSal2.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
That's funny.
This one's from @MisterDorngal.
-Oh, Mister Dorngal.
-58.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
I thought it was dorngal57.
-Oh.
-I don't know dorngal58.
-All right.
[ Laughter ]
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Grunts ]
-Strike!
-This one's from
@JakeWilliamsArt.
-Mm.
-He says...
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
I love curling.
This one's from @drsarahsebree.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
That's true, right?
This one's from @MultiverseSnob.
-Oh.
-They say...
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @TrilloCarl.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
"Jaxxon."
Three X's, yeah.
This one's from @SaiyanaBrief.
They say...
[ Laughter ]
Let's make the thing
go through the thing.
[ Laughs ]
This last one
is from @DDancer42.
They say...
There you have it, everybody.
Those are
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more
of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.